[Music]
developing out of california tonight
three people are dead and 27
others were rescued from the water after
a boat overturned off the coast of san
diego
video shows waves battering the vessel
as it drifts in
you can see the boat tipped sideways
there people aboard try to climb to the
other side of the railing
as others are tossed overboard life
jackets and debris are scattered
throughout the water the boat eventually
breaks into pieces
border patrol agents say this was a
human smuggling situation
so every indication from our perspective
is that this was a smuggling vessel
used to smuggle migrants into the united
states legally we haven't confirmed the
nationality
of the people involved but our agents
are with many of
the hospital and the man who we
believe was the operator agents are with
them and a suspected
smuggler but the investigation is still
unfolding
officials say they have seen an increase
in smuggler boats within the last few
years they haven't confirmed if any
miners were involved in this particular
operation
the captain of the boat is now in
custody